spend five percent of your time planning
strategizing thinking and 95
of your time
doing
executing tactics i call it the 595 rule
five percent of your time
thinking planning strategizing and 95 of
your time actually doing this is where a
lot of entrepreneurs get held up because
we're dreamers we want to change the
world we've got this big mission this
big vision
we've got all these amazing giant planes
and it's so much fun
to sit and think
and plan and watch videos and draft up
what our perfect company our perfect
life the perfect world's going to look
like it's it's a ton of fun anytime you
get entrepreneurs together and you start
dreaming about the future but tell me
about where you want to go what you want
to build those are
really fun easy exercises for us we love
staying there
the problem is none of that stuff
actually happens until you do something
right the perfect world you want to make
the perfect life you want to build none
of that happens until you actually start
doing it think about
working out as an example right you
could you could research all the
exercises you could think about the
beautiful life you're gonna have when
you have your six-pack abs
but nothing counts until you actually
start working out till you start running
and and doing your push-ups and doing
your sit-ups and your squats and all of
that stuff
five percent of your time should be
picking the plan strategizing the plan
and 95 of the time actually do it you
don't want to be in the same spot a year
from today a month from today heck even
a week from today we don't want to stay
stuck you don't want to be in the same
spot you want to be having the same
thoughts to say i wish i could be
further ahead i should be doing
something else like to have the
frustration with yourself your life your
lack of momentum if you don't want to be
stuck in the same spot
one week one month one year from today
the difference is not going to be
different strategies that you come up
with you're you're super smart
you're a smart person and you're doing
this for the right reasons you've got
heart you want to serve
you want to make a difference you want
to feel like what you do matters
the only tweak you have to make
is switching the time you're spending
thinking and pondering and in fear
and
strategizing and moving it
to just doing
to just executing to doing one more
so that's the challenge for today
look at your calendar
for the rest of the today for the rest
of next week
5.95 5 time planning thinking
strategizing and 95 of your time doing
that will make the difference need
motivation watch top 10 with believe
nation
all my life
[Music]
[Applause]
hey it's nina carmichael we made these
videos probably because you're the most
ambitious person in your circle you know
you're capable of more and you need a
push but surround yourself with the best
so today let's learn from one of the
best my husband evan carmichael and
here's our take on his top 10 rules on
success enjoy
rule number two believe the biggest
problem is a lack of belief my biggest
problem your biggest problem the world's
biggest problem is that we don't believe
in ourselves enough you could do great
things you could be the michael jordan
of something you are literally the
greatest in the world at something but
if you don't actually believe that you
are
then you won't be and people with far
less talent far less resources and far
less heart than you will win because
they just took action so my biggest
limitation is still a lack of belief
it's still the thing that holds me back
i'm i believe in my ability to do what
i've already done but not to do the next
thing
it's a constant battle and a constant
reminder because you want to grow i want
to grow i want to keep learning i want
to keep getting better and so to get to
that next breakthrough i'm going to have
to believe in myself to say i can do it
just yesterday i was on a instagram live
with kevin o'leary mr wonderful shark
tank was a super fun interview and the
hour before it
i was just uh totally useless i gave
myself an hour before to prepare to
research to think about what questions i
want to ask to think how i'm going to
introduce him when he comes on
i i don't have a connection to kevin
o'leary before yesterday i've had the
good fortune to meet tons of people and
connect with them but
kevin i haven't done anything with over
the how many years i've had my youtube
channel is crazy so i'm nervous
and in the back of my head is he's a
professional he's it's gonna be great uh
he's not somebody who's like yells at
his you know interviewers it's gonna be
fine but in my my heart i'm still i'm
still nervous i'm still worried i'm
still uh anxious that i'm gonna say the
wrong thing ask the wrong question uh
not give a great interview and you know
it's over in seven minutes was my panic
attack taking over and so that hour
before the interview i was i was
completely useless
um i i kind of went over at least 10
times how i was going to introduce him
and some of my key questions that i was
going to ask him and then i just
basically wasted time
i wasn't in the right mindset to be able
to go and do anything else i couldn't
even do instagram dms or emails because
i was too distracted thinking about this
thing that was coming up
but what's the alternative you know
whenever you face those doubts whenever
you face those fears the alternative is
say no the alternative is oh
i can't do it i'm i'm i'm busy find some
excuse right evan of 10 years ago
probably would have backed out of it
would have found some reason why i
couldn't have done it i'm busy uh you
know find something some find some
reason
i want to teach myself that i do scary
things that i do difficult things that i
lean into the thing if i don't believe
in myself enough then i have to go do
the thing to show myself that i believe
in myself you can say all day long i
believe in myself i believe in myself i
believe but if you don't do the thing
you won't believe in yourself
and so
you do it scared you do it when it's
hard you do it when it's difficult even
if i go on the live and
just say the wrong thing to kevin and
insult him or he leaves or something
happens the fact that i showed up with
with with a positive intention with the
goal to try to make this a great
interview is enough for me to pat myself
on the back and say i did it now the
interview ended up going great at least
i thought i thought it went well we had
a good conversation we talked about his
new business i made a new connection he
now follows me on instagram it was it
was a fun time and logically
you might be watching and thinking of
well of course it's going to work out
you've done all these interviews and
logically to myself it's the same thing
of course it's going to work out i've
done all these interviews and with
harder people to talk to than kevin
o'leary
but in the moment when you're talking
the logic isn't enough to get you
through it at least for me it's it's the
boom boom boom test that my heart's
beating boom boom boom boom boom i'm
nervous i'm scared i have to do it
that's how you start building confidence
belief self-respect by doing difficult
things now i've got a three-step process
i'm going to walk you through to help
you get more self-belief number one is
be surrounded by it be surrounded by the
things that make you believe in yourself
more this is so critical because chances
are the people around you aren't
encouraging you to be more aren't
pushing you saying you're capable of so
much more a lot of people have either
haters around them people telling them
that you're never gonna make it be safe
be practical go get this safe job over
here you can't go do that or people who
might
have empathy might have some kind of
understanding but they don't know how to
push you to do greater things and so you
have to be surrounded by the people who
make you feel like more as possible this
is so critical it's so important it's
why i make this youtube channel i want
you to start your day with confidence
and belief so if this channel does it
for you great hey every day i'm making
videos if not on this channel i've got
lots of other channels also making
content but if it's not me then it's
somebody else if it's dean's channel or
dean's books or dean's podcast that
makes you feel bold confident alive
powerful then then be surrounded by it
as much as possible have it as a part of
your regular schedule have it in your
environment look at my environment here
look at the people on the wall behind me
i walk into here and these people make
me believe in myself more from steve
jobs to ap janine to my parents howard
chills kanye west these people make me
believe in myself more
from from the cell phone background that
i have can i load it up it says it says
remember your intention
remember your intention ah you can see
it hey you can see it it works remember
your intention as a reminder reminder
for myself my desktop background the
clothes that i wear right i feel like
i'm batman going to work i feel like i'm
a superhero going to work to try to
change the world for the better every
time i put this on now that might seem
crazy to you that might seem stupid
childish ridiculous awesome go do you
but think about it from your office
environment to you know the screens on
your phone and computer to what you wear
it impacts your psychology it impacts
your self-confidence so you want to be
around it as much as possible physical
environment plus online environment from
the the music you listen to the podcast
the videos you're watching
to every day inject that belief into
yourself step number two is fix your
morning routine
most people well most people don't have
morning routine so most of america
doesn't have a morning routine but if
you're watching this video you probably
have some kind of morning routine most
people wake up like an accident you
probably wake up and have a morning
routine and so your friends and family
people who look at you they might even
be in awe of your morning routine and
say how do you accomplish so much and
how you stick to that morning routine
you're the one that people are going to
for advice on morning routines
but your morning routine is likely still
broken
you know what the most important part of
a morning routine is
it's not brushing your teeth it's not uh
you know meditation it's not even
watching one of these espresso videos as
much as that breaks my heart
the thing that's most important in the
morning routine is do you get the
feeling of belief of unstoppable
confidence of boldness when you finish
it
too many people are just checking the
boxes too many people are saying well
okay i'm going to wake up i'm going to
brush my teeth i'm going to read a book
i'm going to work out i'm going to ask
great check check check check check
check check perfect you checked all the
boxes you did it
but you don't feel bold
you don't have confidence you don't feel
the belief
why
well one of two reasons one either your
morning routine is broken and you
actually have to inject something in you
have to actually watch that video or
make that call or do that meditation or
say that prayer or whatever the thing is
you have to add something into your
morning routine to get the confidence
or two your morning routine actually is
okay
you're just not doing it with intention
so remember my cell phone screen here
right remember your intention remember
mine this is how do i there we go
remember your intention this is a
constant reminder for myself
to remember my intention
your morning routine
you might have all the right pieces to
it and maybe watching a video is the
thing that gets you feeling fired up and
ready to go and have that belief but if
you're watching a video while you're
doing something else if you're watching
a video while you're brushing your teeth
or while you're
planning out your day or while you're
making your lunch or something else and
you've only got half your brain on it
and you're not actually too focused on
it then great check
you watch the video you can check it off
your morning list but you don't feel the
feeling
and if you don't feel the feeling if you
don't feel bold powerful unstoppable
confident coming out of your morning
routine then you need to immediately fix
your morning routine for tomorrow it's
one of the single greatest things that
you can do because if you woke up and
did the thing that made you feel belief
confidence boldness every day
if that's how you started your day you
actually felt that every day your life
is gonna look dramatically different
when you're from today i guarantee fix
your morning routine and step number
three is pass the boom boom boom test
and the boom boom boom test is when your
heart's beating boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom boom
that's a sign to go that's a sign to do
that's a sign of your your beliefs in
yourself being questioned when i had
kevin o'leary coming up on my show boom
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom right
even having dean on my show
i had dean not too long ago on my show
and now i know dean better we've hung
out in puerto rico he's been on a couple
times already we spent some time
together so uh he's he's a closer friend
than kevin o'leary who i didn't know
before now the last time i had dean on
it was to promote his book but i
couldn't bring him in for more than a
couple seconds
instagram i'd bring him in and he would
crash and so i tried to bring him in and
then we'd crash again so and i tried
like four or five times to try to bring
him in and he's sitting there live and
it just keeps crashing and it felt so
terrible it's like oh my my worst
nightmare is coming true right like it
didn't work out oh my gosh i feel so bad
i'm letting him down and letting my
audience down live
it just felt terrible
and so in the back of my head is oh my
gosh remember the last time i tried to
have dean on
the the fiasco that happened and so boom
boom boom boom boom boom i don't want it
to happen again this time
but not letting the boom boom boom this
is just your fear talking right this is
a lack of belief talking it's a lack of
belief that it's gonna go well this time
you can't let that
hold you back from actually doing the
thing and quite often what happens is
you feel the boom boom boom boom boom
right it's going like this
but then your brain will find some
reason why you can't do it your brain
will talk you down from doing the thing
you'll find a really logical smart
reason because you won't believe a
stupid reason a really smart reason why
you can't do the thing and so you don't
but really you're just afraid and so
this helps you catch it when you feel
the boom boom boom it's going like this
your heart's beating i'm scared i'm
doing that thing i'm doing that thing
i'm gonna reward myself for the effort
whether it ends up working out or not
because i do scary things and so do you
rule number three make a shift to your
calendar the fact that you look at your
calendar today tomorrow next week and
nothing excites you okay great what can
you shift and it may require a wholesale
change it may require you
doing some drastic thing but more likely
you could probably just do one small
shift
like just start building momentum
just start doing one little thing every
day
to start to train yourself to start to
just push the ball
a little bit forward because often we
think we have to make some giant change
and the only answer is to move to mexico
and then it never happens because to
move to mexico takes you however many
you know months and budget and all this
stuff you get stuck in planning but
instead of doing
what's a small step what's a small tweak
that you can make to today's calendar
to inject more energy into it what's
something that you're going to love
doing that will give you more energy
that then now you have energy for other
things as well right some kind of
immediate momentum rule number four fear
regret the fear of regret is one of the
most powerful
tools at your disposal to help you get
into action mode
let me explain whatever you want to do
whatever your goals are your your
mission your mission your dreams
whatever you want to do
if it's big enough it's going to have
some fear attached to it right you don't
want to just do the same thing over and
over and over and over and over again so
therefore your dreams your ambitions
your drive require you to do things that
are scary that are new that are
different that are pushing you outside
your comfort zone and our natural
reaction is we don't want to do those
things
right in theory we do when we feel bold
and confident we do when you watch a
video like this you get inspired and
motivated like yes i'm going to go do it
and then when it comes time to actually
doing it
you find a reason why you can't do it
right too tired i'll do it tomorrow
there's always some logical reason why
you can't do it meanwhile it's just fear
understand that under underneath your
excuses your reasons are just fear it's
just fear you're afraid of doing the
thing you're afraid of being judged
you're afraid of who will see it you're
afraid of who won't see it you're afraid
of nobody's seeing it you're just afraid
you're afraid
and getting to your dreams require you
to step through that fear
and the future regret
the fear of future regret
is so powerful because it can knock you
out of the immediate fear of doing the
thing
so let me break it down
if you had to
make a video you're gonna make a video
you know i'm making a video right now
right if i was afraid of making this
video i'm afraid to make this video i'm
afraid of i'm gonna have the wrong words
i'm afraid that nina's gonna judge me
for the words that i'm saying
i'm afraid that my dogs are not going to
be happy with me whatever you're afraid
of of what what that guy thinks
for for me with with my phone right
you're you're afraid all these things
come through our
our head of what we're afraid we're
afraid of and by the way nina's very
supportive as always we love you neyman
anyway you're afraid so if you're afraid
of making a video great
the fear the present fear is very real
it feels
it feels big right let's call it let's
put it on a fear score the fear of
actually making that video
is a 50 okay it's a score of 50. that's
how much afraid we are to do it
it's a 50.
the fear of the regret
of not doing it in the moment it's not
very big maybe it's a one
right it's just a one it's a one
the the the idea that okay i might
regret this one day whatever it's a one
but the problem is
50 is just for today that little fear of
well it's a big fear but in the moment
of doing the one thing say it's a 50.
it's just today the regret compounds so
it's it's it's one today it's one
tomorrow and it's one the next day it's
one the next days one the next day it
actually ends up being a million right
it ends up being huge
the fear of inaction becomes
huge
but we don't feel it on a day-to-day
basis because it's too small compared to
the present fear of doing the thing so
what you have to do
and this is the this is the hack you get
out of procrastination unless you need
it this is the hack to get into action
mode this is the hack too actually start
chasing your dreams down believe nation
come on let's go
is to make
the fear so big
of regret that you're gonna miss out
that this video that you're about to
make today is going to be the video that
is life cha altering life changing life
redefining for you
this one thing that you're about to do
is gonna be the greatest moment of your
life
so you make that pain so big
that now it becomes a million
versus the 50.
right so then it's not as as scary to go
do the thing
because there's a bigger fear you're
basically inflicting a future pain so
big on you that the present pain doesn't
feel as big also if you want to have
more self-confidence and self-belief the
sign says it can take up a 254 days of
consecutive action for you to build a
habit so i've created a special free
program to help you where every day for
254 days i will send you an email that
has a link to an unlisted video that if
you watch it will boost your confidence
forward the link to join for free is in
the description below if you're doing
work that you love you're more likely to
follow through you're more likely to do
it because it doesn't feel like work
because you love doing it don't worry
what the first step is people write in
and say what's my first it doesn't
matter something do something and then
do something again tomorrow and do
something again the next day and every
day you get a little bit better they're
great because they can help you one
navigate the waters of dealing with
publishers and creating a proposal
that's really going to win because you
might only get one shot with the
publisher so she has a new author and if
your proposal sucks they likely won't
want to look at it again unless you've
done something dramatic on your audience
size to really build up notoriety around
yourself rule number five love the
process you can get great at almost any
skill uh almost any skill
you could get great at if you wanted to
if you dedicated yourself to practicing
if you dedicated yourself to model and
success if you dedicated yourself to
doing it you could get great at almost
any skill now
you know where people go with this as
the the extreme like well i i can't
become
you know a seven footer in the nba like
okay great if you're 5'2 you know you
might not be able to be a seven foot in
the nba right
but
but just think about it think about your
goals think about your dreams think
about where you want to go
what you want to do is possible
stop looking at all the the rare
exceptions of how you can't do it and
instead focus on how you can
[Music]
where we struggle
is because the things that we need to
get great at
we probably aren't very good at that
this is a really big deal for
entrepreneurs because you're probably
good at some things you're probably
naturally good at some things or you had
some training or your parents put you
into classes and you developed a skill
set at something but you may not like
that thing like this is this is the
trick
we're good at things that we don't like
doing
you're probably really good at a lot of
things that you don't want to actually
now commit the rest of your life to
doing
and so this creates the dilemma this
creates an entrepreneur's dilemma
we should name it something maybe it's
the entrepreneur's dilemma
where
you have two choices
you either focus on what you're good at
that can get you paid
that can
get you a job that can maybe even have
you start your business you're good at
it you can get paid doing it but it
is not something you enjoy and the more
you do it
you soul you slowly start to lose your
soul it slowly starts to be life sucking
for you like imagine this thing that
you're good at that you don't like doing
just imagine you close your eyes you're
daydreaming imagine that you had to do
this thing for the next 40 years of your
life
how much would you hate your life if you
keep doing those things
so it's that you keep doing the things
that you're good at but you don't like
versus the things that you want to be
good at
that you really love but right now you
suck at it
that's the hardest thing for people like
you want to get good at this other thing
that's where your passion is that's
where your heart is but you don't have
the skills yet and so a lot of
entrepreneurs where they quit that's
where a lot of you will quit you'll quit
you'll stop because you're not good at
it it's like oh wow i suck at it
and so i guess i'll never be good at it
and so then you don't do it
where all you need to do is flip it to
say okay
i don't suck as a human
i don't i don't i'm not good at the
skill set yet but i can get good at it
how do i get good get good at is by
practicing
when i first started making videos
everything is against me right if you
look at who i was where i came from my
personality my thought process
everything was against me for making
videos let me let me break it down let
me actually take you into the early days
of evan carmichael making youtube videos
i am shy
i am introverted
uh i don't like disappointing people i
have no need to be famous you know i
don't i don't like the spotlight i
actually would rather be at the back of
the room instead of you know on stage
all of this doesn't sound good for
somebody who's
just
then gonna go make videos turning on the
camera terrified me uh i'm filming here
in a parking lot right or my wife is
shopping at at costco there um
i would never be able to do this you
know there's people walking by this
would this would freak me out
i would say who's that who's that crazy
guy in the car doing that thing
you know on paper i guess everything
looked like it was against me
i made a video
because i had this idea to make a video
because i'm a visual learner
i think your purpose comes from your
pain
i struggled so much as an entrepreneur i
wanted to make the road a little bit
easier for other entrepreneurs
and so i made one video
and it was it was not the greatest
experience
i was terrified
i was sitting down i was in a suit i was
nervous i was memorizing the script
because i was so worried that i was
going to say the wrong words
and people wouldn't like my video
they can go back and watch the first one
i did on walt disney
and it took a day or whatever to make
this one short video and i'm not even on
camera for most of it
most of it is
me doing an audio
because i could i could read it
i wanted to read the script i had the
perfect script
and there was b-roll on top of it it was
very little of me actually on camera but
even those few lines i had on camera i
was terrified and i was trying to
memorize and i was sweating and
i was funny sitting down in a suit all
that was hilarious
i wasn't very good at it
i wasn't very good at it but there was
something about it that i just liked
i liked it i liked the idea
none of it made sense
right again there was no option to be
youtube famous nobody was youtube famous
uh in in education in 2009 when i first
started it didn't exist
and my personality of being introverted
shy all that did not lend itself well to
being
a personality
but for some reason even though
everything was seemingly against me on
paper i just i liked it
and i wasn't very good at it but i
thought you know what i can get better
i'm gonna keep doing this thing
and it took me
you could see my stats and i post it
often to to my instagram once a month
it's an update of how my channel is
doing from the first video that i posted
it took five years to get to 9 000
subscribers
five years to get the 9 000 subscriber a
lot of you guys are already way ahead of
that after your first year of just
making content
you're already ahead
and then i went five years again from
the 9 000 to you know 2 million
see there's a person next to me right
now
try to film her this would freak me out
i'm going to be filming here making a
video where this person's right next to
me how is she judging me what is she
thinking what is she doing you know i'd
get super distracted i wouldn't be able
to film content
so it took me 350 videos until i wasn't
completely embarrassed by myself
embarrassed like i couldn't watch back
my own videos they were too painful to
watch i would look at it i would judge
myself or to criticize myself i would i
would say man you're still not very good
i would find a million things that was
wrong with the video just so many so
many things that
i was not happy with
350 public videos guys 350
and then it took 700 videos until i
inspired myself until i watched the back
i said man i'm you know what this i'm
starting to get decent at this you know
there's something there maybe maybe i
have a future here
700 public videos later it's crazy
so what what kept me through it what
kept me
consistent how did i keep going because
the mission yes of of
wanting to help serve entrepreneurs but
also i liked i liked it i liked the
process of doing it there was something
again even though it didn't make sense
for someone like me to do it i liked it
it was fun
and so i kept going and you know now
we're
over 10 000 videos later still making
content still doing it and
not
burning out because i like the process
if you love what you're doing you're not
gonna burn out rule number six set a
deadline for too many of us there's no
deadline when's the deadline on your
dreams when's the deadline to make your
content what's the deadline to actually
execute things for most of us there's no
deadline you don't have a deadline and
so because you don't have the deadline
you allow yourself to procrastinate
and to and to tinker on to make things
perfect and to never release because
there's no deadline it doesn't matter
enough
when i'm making videos i have to make a
certain number of videos every week for
my channels
and there's a deadline i have to get
them done today they have to get done
today because tomorrow i'm doing
something else and the next day i'm
doing something else and i'm not
touching my youtube content again until
next tuesday
so if i don't get it done today then my
team doesn't have content to go off and
create for the channels and then i'm
disappointing you
and it's been i don't know seven or
eight years since we haven't not since
we have not haven't not since we have
not uploaded a video on one of our
channels
years it's been years
years of consistency
and that's
how you start to build the machine
because there's a deadline because it
matters because it's important today
rule number seven have a constant
reminder have a reminder system in your
life constantly
what are the things because you're
feeling it right now hopefully if you're
watching you're feeling it right now
you're feeling excited right now you're
going to make a change right now and
then tomorrow you're going to fall back
to who you used to be so what what do
you need in your environment what do you
need in your habits in your daily
routines to remind you you need to
remind your system so it can become more
automatic that it doesn't rely on your
self-will and your discipline constantly
that it gets introduced to you
constantly whether that's
uh youtube videos why hey espresso five
days a week every morning i'm here let's
go here's a new video for you uh if it's
edmund's channel or tony robbins channel
or or oprah winfrey's videos like
whoever or if it's books or podcasts if
it's your physical environment if it's
uh
morning intention like just figure it
out for yourself
and schedule it in
schedule in the reminders
schedule in the intentionality so that
this doesn't just become a one-off
moment but that it's a daily reminder
it's a daily consistency it's daily
momentum because you need that rule
number eight choose to be happy
happiness comes down to fulfillment
versus excitement when people ask me hey
evan how do you how do you define
happiness it's one of the most common
questions i get asked when i'm doing
interviews and podcasts and such what
does happiness look like to you well
happiness
is
fulfillment and excitement
because it's very interesting
word so let's break it down
fulfillment is feeling like what you do
matters
you're happy when you feel like what you
do matters you're happy when you feel
like
you wake up today and today is gonna
matter
this is what we all want we all wanna
feel like what we're going to do today
is going to have an impact on somebody
else's life we are all built to serve
you want to feel important to somebody
else not just from a ego perspective
that oh i matter and i'm important but
in a way that you contributed to
somebody else's life we're all connected
we want to feel connected we want to
feel like
this is going to matter today that this
video that i make for you even though
i'm here just in the car by myself
well nina's actually nina's back there
hello nina even though
i'm just here filming by myself in the
car i want to feel like this video is
touching somebody it's touching you that
you guys are watching it and hopefully
the message here is going to be
inspiring and helpful to you in some way
we all want that that's fulfillment
right
if you wake up too many days in a row
and you feel like today it doesn't
matter nobody cares if i show up nobody
cares if i do a good job or not nobody
cares that's a fast path to the
depression and worst case suicide right
that's where a lot of people
unfortunately are living right now is
they don't feel like they matter they're
not happy because there's no fulfillment
they're not happy because they feel like
they don't matter to anybody
so that's fulfillment the other side of
happiness is excitement you're happy
when you feel like you're doing
something new you're happy when you get
to try something new you get to have fun
you get to do something that hasn't been
done before you're you're you're
going out of your comfort zone or you're
you're having this quick hit right i
mean it could be anything from i'm
excited to have my coffee you know i'm
excited to have my starbucks you know
when we go once a week to film we get a
starbucks put some cream in and i'm
excited for the taste right you could be
excited for that donut or that meal
you know it may not even be good for you
the donut's not good for you but you're
still excited to have it because it
tastes so good you're chasing this
little momentary high or you could be
excited to go on that vacation you're
excited just something new this it's a
it's a moment in time it's the little
it's the candy it's the sweets
right and it's the sweets of life
it's not sustainable but it's not
designed to be sustainable
it's these little moments in time that
make us happy and that's true too but
that's why it's excitement
jumping from an airplane you know it's
exciting
it's not sustainable
you're not going to show up every day
and fall from the airplane all day long
right and so i think where a lot of
people struggle a lot of entrepreneurs
especially is we're chasing the
excitement only
you're you're chasing what it's going to
feel like when you hit your goal when
you have a million subscribers or a
million in revenue or whatever
success looks like to you
well what we're missing is the
fulfillment part of it there's nothing
wrong with chasing those goals there's
nothing wrong with having that caffeine
high that sugar rush that you know hey i
hit my goal amazing there's nothing
wrong with it but if that's all there is
you need the meal
right if that's all there is you're
never actually going to be happy because
those are just moments in time
that you're you get excited today if
that something happened and then you
might wait another month before the next
exciting thing happens we're just
adrenaline junkies this is what
entrepreneurs are a lot of entrepreneurs
just become adrenaline junkies chasing
the next high
that's not sustainable that's not
healthy and that's not ultimate
happiness
you have to pair it with the fulfillment
when you can do both
that i'm i'm chasing these big goals
these big dreams or even something small
i can do right now to get excited
and pairing it with what i do matters
this is fulfilling to me this is going
to make a difference in somebody's life
that's where i think you have long-term
sustainable healthy forms of happiness
the good news is both of them you can
accomplish right now
at any point in time
you could choose to help somebody you
could choose to go serve somebody right
at any point in time it could be you
know
helping those people put the groceries
in their car right they could go go help
them or take the shopping cart and and
put it away for them random act of
kindness it could be going to somebody's
youtube comments and leaving a nice
message think about
a creator that you like to follow
somebody else that you subscribe to who
maybe doesn't have as big a following go
leave a nice message how long does it
take you to do
right 18 seconds you just made a
difference in somebody's life
right
responding to somebody who follows you
on instagram and saying hey thank you
for following me on instagram i really
appreciate you that's how i built my
instagram following i'd be sitting here
at a costco individually messaging
people who followed me to say hey rick
hey susan hey jennifer thank you so much
for following me i really appreciate you
thank you send next right
seven seconds eight seconds 15 seconds
at a time
you can choose at any point
to be happy rule number nine be positive
i think you're a tree and i wrote about
this in my book built to serve i think
you're a tree what does a tree do a tree
breathes in the carbon dioxide which
too much of for humans is poison
we breathe the trees will breathe it in
they'll eat it they'll grow from it and
then they'll spit out oxygen positivity
for the world i see that as part of our
role as leaders and as entrepreneurs is
to
eat other people's negativity grow from
it get better from it and then spit out
more positivity more oxygen for the
world ultimately the people who are
negative in your life you have an
ability to influence them you have an
ability to help them see the positive
road not through your
advice but through your actions by you
going off and doing your thing
will inspire other people to want to
change their life as well whoever is
more confident wins and when you're
around
really negative people
if you are doubting your positivity
they're going to win they're going to
drag you down
but ultimately the goal is to get so
positive so optimistic so
so happy
that you pull them up
that you're more positive you're more
certain in your positivity than they are
certain in their negativity and you pull
them
towards making a better life decision
rule number 10 the last one before our
very special bonus clip make work fun i
have a list of beliefs that i read every
morning every single morning i have it
written on my computer i pop it up and
these are the lists of beliefs and
values that i want to remind myself of
that i want to live today and every day
and i find that reminding myself of it
in the morning helps make sure that i
actually follow through on it during the
day and so one of those things that i
read to myself every morning is that
work is play one of the beliefs that i
want to espouse on a daily basis is that
work is play that work isn't just work
that work isn't a place to go and die
work isn't a place to go and struggle
and yes work is a lot of hard work right
work is a lot of a grind work is a lot
of getting stuff done and checking a lot
of things off the list right you want to
be productive and feel like you're
creating meaningful value in the world
today but it doesn't have to suck like
work can be fun and it's partly enjoying
the work having passion for what you're
doing right doing something that you
feel is meaningful but also just having
fun with it and so if i look at some of
the things that i do you know in our
office environment i had alex and lily
over and they started breaking out into
a song
and in the morning when i'm making
videos for my my book you'll see me on
snapchat with you know rabbit ears or
raccoon ears or some fun filter on it
and fun is different to each person
right i'm not the guy who's going to be
out cracking jokes
that's maybe more alex's style
but the point is that you're doing the
things that you can express your
creativity through that you are having
fun with if you are on your way to your
office whether your office is your
basement or your home office or an
actual office where you have your
employees and team members if you're on
your way to go and do work
and you are dreading it
like another day and it's like it feels
like the world is beating you down
you're not gonna create great work like
if you feel like you have to just plow
through a whole bunch of crap every day
it's not gonna feel fun you're not gonna
create an amazing experience and so if
you can approach it with how can i have
fun today it's just asking that question
how can i make this fun it's not by
taking breaks right it's not by doing
something in between to break up the
crap right it's not okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna grind through this for two hours
and then i'm gonna i'm gonna take a
celebration and go grab a coffee and
then come back and i'm gonna grind up
some more it's like how can you make the
grind fun
how can you inject fun into the actual
process so that you are enjoying the
process because you can get to that
point it's not that every single minute
of every day is going to be amazing but
if you get to that point where work is
play where work is fun you're not just
going to have more fun but it's going to
show in the result as well it's going to
show in what you create you're going to
create better things it's going to add
more value it's going to help you grow
your business much more than if you go
to work every day feeling like the world
is crushing you down now i've got a
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week when you
watch a video and just get motivated you
have a 35 chance of actually following
through that's what the science says and
that is not good enough believe nation
we need to do better when you actually
get motivated and then create a specific
plan of action for what you're going to
do this week you have a 91 chance of
following through and when you publicly
commit to somebody else like leaving a
comment below in this video it jumps
even higher so i want that for you i
want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week so i can
celebrate with you
entrepreneurship is one of the hardest
things that you're ever going to do in
your life
and it's totally worth it
it's totally worth it whether it
actually works out or not most
entrepreneurs will fail something like
85 percent of businesses fail in the
first five years most businesses won't
work but it's totally worth it why
because
you're showing yourself that you bet on
yourself you're showing yourself that
you're following through and taking
action on your ideas that you're worthy
you're showing yourself that you're
worthy
you're showing yourself that you believe
in you
and if you keep doing that
you're gonna win
the path to living a happy life a
fulfilled life a life that you're proud
of
is one where you continue to show up for
yourself and the minute that you stop
when you stop showing up for yourself
when you
just throw in the towel and say this is
over i'm just going to work for somebody
else i'm going to help somebody else
build their dreams instead of chasing
down mine
that's when life starts to fall apart
you know that's the path down
to unhappiness and depression and it
doesn't mean that everybody has to be an
entrepreneur
but what you have to do is continue to
bet on yourself you have to continue to
bet on your ideas you have to continue
to say i came up with this good idea
and because i came up with it therefore
it's a worthy endeavor for me to chase
it down
i got asked on my live stream yesterday
how do i know when to quit you know is
quitting is quitting bad
do i quit on something how do i know
when to quit
some people say never give up never give
up always keep going and some people
are the opposites what's the right
advice
the right answer is if you love it you
have to keep going
[Music]
if you love it you have you have to find
a way to keep going
so for a lot of cases that's what
entrepreneurship is you've got a dream
you got a mission you got some goals
that that you genuinely love that you
really want to to build to create to
serve to help people with
and it's that love that's going to keep
you going
because in the early days it's going to
suck it's the it's the
chewing glass and eating to the abyss
right you have that moment of high at
the beginning of i'm gonna start this
thing oh my god it's so exciting and
then you you land into the valley of no
momentum nothing working not no results
nobody praising you anymore nobody's
celebrating you for starting the
business
now you're in the actual running of it
and you're not getting the results that
you want and you're trying to
show how you're winning and post it on
instagram and you're but you're not and
you know you're not and you feel like a
fraud
and this is this is the life cycle that
a lot of entrepreneurs go through
but if you love it
you have to keep going you have to you
have to you have to
you could be a lot more honest you could
be a lot more vulnerable you could be a
lot more authentic
you can understand that you have you
don't have to do this all by yourself
this is my biggest problem when i
started my company i was i was failing i
was flat out failing i was 300 bucks a
month like
failing
and i was too embarrassed and ashamed to
tell my friends that i was feeling i
wanted to look like
i was doing well because i turned down
the jobs that they all went and got and
they're all making
high five figure low six figure jobs at
a university and i'm
making
300 bucks a month i was just embarrassed
i was just too embarrassed and i made it
harder on myself
to be alone
you don't have to be alone you can make
it easier by just letting people in
when you're down in the dumps being by
yourself is usually the worst thing
if you can be around other people
especially people who support you
a lot of people will
let's circle back to
the idea that if you don't love it
you're gonna regret it why why do you
have to keep going
why do you have to keep going why is it
so important if you love it because you
will regret it
because you will look back on this
moment in your life and say i should
have
done more i could have done more i
regret not giving it one more week one
more month
one more year i regret it you will
regret it that's the only thing that
saved my first business
i quit on my partner i told him i'm done
i need to feel like i'm a valuable human
again nothing i'm doing is working and i
hate how this makes me feel as a person
nothing against
you or the business just how i feel i
need to feel like i'm valuable again
somehow
that was the conversation and then the
next day woke up and i said i can't quit
because i'm going to regret this i know
i'm going to regret this i'm going to be
an old man at 40.
i'm 41 now i'm getting an old man at 40
and regret that i wasted my life and i
didn't do this thing
and that's the only thing that gave me
the the courage
the motivation the energy to get back up
and just keep going you will regret this
if you love it and you stop now you will
regret this for your entire life
now on the flip side i think there are
many things that you should quit on
sooner
the the difference is if you don't love
it you need to quit on it if you don't
love it anymore and maybe you never
loved it in the first place then you
need to move on because you will never
win doing work that you hate
the people who are at the top of their
game people have i've studied how many
successful people have i studied and
profiled and showcased on on all of
these channels how many so many people
right
the one thing they all have in common is
that they love what they do they love
the process they love the work they love
the grind it's not a grind for them
because they're in it so much and they
love it
so that's who you're going up against
right and if you don't love it you're
always going to lose no matter how smart
you are you're going to lose because
you're going up against people who
absolutely love the thing
and so that's what you need you need to
be loving your thing and so if you're in
it just as a strategy
you're going to lose move on immediately
as soon as your heart's not into it
either sell it or if it's too new then
then you just flat out move on i think
people saying relationships are too long
i think people stay in businesses for
too long because you're afraid of
failure because you're afraid of what it
means if you quit on something and go to
something else you're afraid of what
people are gonna say you're afraid of
what the person looking back at you in
the mirror is gonna think if you quit
you're afraid of the uncertainty of
where to go next because if this thing
at least i know what this thing is doing
i don't know what the future holds to me
if i go somewhere else
a lot of people are handcuffed by having
a little bit of money not not a lot but
enough to survive
and that then prevents them from taking
the next jump which they actually need
to do because their heart's not in the
thing
so many people start a business because
they're just trying to make money
people ask me what's what's the number
one
business to get into for this year to
make a lot of money that's the wrong
question you're asking that question
you're going to lose
you can't start with how to make money
you start with the thing that you love
that brings value and inside of that
you're making money making money is
important a hundred percent if you don't
make money you will not have a business
making money has to be in your top five
of priorities but if you make it number
one you're gonna lose because you're
always gonna be chasing the next hot
thing
never get good enough at anything to
actually be the best in the world which
is actually how you start to make a lot
of money you need to be the best in the
world at something how do you get that
by loving the things so much
and by wanting to serve and help people
get better at it too
that's how you win the problem isn't
that you're not a genius that you're not
talented that you don't have wisdom and
abilities and resourcefulness and that
you're not michael jordan that's not the
problem the problem is you're not
focused you're not doing the things that
you need to do i just came back from
video marketing world in dallas and i
was being asked about where to spend
your time which social media sites to
spend time on and i think this is a
classic example of where entrepreneurs
fail is you're trying to do everything
and as a result you suck everywhere and
feel burnt out tapped out and not
building momentum if you get to the end
of a week
and you feel like you worked your face
off but you look back what did i get
done
if that's how you're ending a week you
worked hard and you feel like what did i
get done you're not focused you're
switching between tasks too much
instead of having all of these social
media sites at the same time pick one
and crush it
i quoted andrew carnegie at my event and
my speech my favorite quote from him is
put all your eggs in one basket and then
watch that basket everybody's saying
diversify diversify diversify have 18
different multiple streams of income
look at the people who are who are one
person show with 18 streams of income
they're making no money
you're making 10 a month from this and
25 a month from that and 18 cents from
this you're not making money
now as you build and scale and grow and
you have a team like i do i've got 24
people on my team okay great now it
might be time to diversify but as a solo
person you can't do everything yourself
and you are a genius you have michael
jordan level talent at something and
that's what you need to find and that's
we need to spend as much time as
possible on until you're making money
you can invest back into your business
and continue to grow i think everyone is
born an optimist and then your
environment sucks the soul out of most
people when you're a baby you don't
stress out about how you look what
you're wearing or how you're smelling
when you're a kid you don't hate your
life and complain about the world if
there's negativity in your head it was
put there by someone and if you want to
change it you need to change your
environment so i've had the good
pleasure of seeing one of my friends
mark drager great friend of the channel
been involved with the channel for a
number of years become more optimistic
become more positive and he was
wondering could i even do it is it
possible he was a guy who was naturally
naturally pessimistic he had a lot of
stuff happen to him like we all have a
lot of situations a lot of circumstances
that made him see the the negative of
what's happening of be pessimistic of
not being the typical
optimistic everything's going to work
out great entrepreneur and so what
changed over the past 12 months he's
made a significant investment in himself
i've been hanging around with him a lot
more we've co-hosted a podcast together
he's hanging around me my content
garyvee's content tom bill used content
more he's been the tony robbins seminar
twice in the past year brought his team
with him
and he's slowly inching towards more
optimism more positivity that more
things are possible
because of the negative upbringing that
he had it takes a lot of unwiring it
takes a lot of shift in your focus it
takes a lot of with purpose with intent
changing your environment changing the
people you hang out with changing where
you the physical environment that you're
in
to make a change
i went to mark's office and he's moving
his office he's creating his own office
he's putting a picture on the wall of
himself and then what he wants to be as
as positive inspiration every day he's
looking at what kind of colors and what
kind of furnishings and what kind of the
core can i have in my office to make me
feel bold to make me feel alive every
single day
it's possible and i think that's the
starting point for a lot of people it's
possible to change your outlook it's
possible to become more optimistic that
negativity that was planted in your head
was put there by somebody else who hates
their life you are not born to wake up
and hate your life you're not born to
wake up and think that it's just
negativity all around the world you're
not born to wake up and be a pessimist
you're not it was put there by somebody
somebody else who hated their life and
we need to eject that person we need to
unwire the years or decades of training
and in that void you replace it with the
thing that you want
if you want more optimism you you
surround yourself with the most
optimistic people you can find
in person on your team in video format
in the books you read and the clubs
you're hanging out with you first limit
access from the negative people
limit exposure you may not be able to
completely wipe them out like maybe
they're your parents but you can limit
exposure you limit access either with
time or just topics that you're covering
and then inject more positivity and
optimism to the people books resources
environment that you have around you you
need to make the big decisions in your
life with your heart and the small ones
with your head this is where so many
entrepreneurs fall down this is where so
many entrepreneurs make mistakes because
you see a trend you see an opportunity
you see something that makes sense it
just makes sense on paper it's so clear
this is gonna happen
but if it doesn't energize you if you
don't love it if it's not in your heart
to say i can't wait to go off and do
that thing you're never gonna win you're
never gonna win because you're going up
against people who love it
you're going up against people who love
it who breathe it who sleep it who dream
about it and for you it's just an
opportunity you're never gonna win big
look at all your heroes all your mentors
people you look up to the people who've
done it like i want to be like this
person in my field i want to be i want
to do it like she did it like he did it
they love doing the thing
they love doing the thing doing it gives
them energy
i look at what i do i'm here in dallas
i'm about to speak at video marketing
world an annual summit of some of the
top creators on youtube to help share
give back help the community give
feedback train on youtube i love doing
this stuff
what am i i'm in the parking lot filming
videos for you guys not because it's a
strategy not because i need to make a
video a day because i love it this this
is this is the best i'm about to go into
this meeting to this conference and i'm
going to hang out with entrepreneurs all
day long
from the time i get in there until
whatever time a.m i'm going to be
hanging out with entrepreneurs and
helping them with their business helping
them with their channel because i love
it
and if that sounds exhausting for you
amazing don't do it and if it sounds
energizing for you yes go and do it you
need to make the big decisions with your
heart and then your head's still
important it's like don't list it's not
the message is not don't listen to logic
the message is not don't look for
opportunities it's look for
opportunities within the thing that you
love
right if i love making videos and i love
making content and i love helping
entrepreneurs but i went all in on my
space right now i'm gonna lose
it's not the right strategy right you
need both
it's working hard plus working smart
it's following what you love doing plus
chasing opportunities but what takes
precedence what's the most important
thing your heart
the energy if you're saying oh man
monday
if that's your mindset around monday
you're doing the wrong thing you're in
the wrong career you're in the wrong
business you will never be the top
player in your industry it'll never
happen for you if that's your mindset
if you're itching to get back to it if
you can't wait to go to that meeting
can't wait to code can't wait to make
that piece of art can't wait to go and
make that video can't wait to sit down
and write lyrics for your next song if
that's the thing
then you're going to be successful it's
not going to be easy it's still a long
road it's still a path you still have to
put in the grind and the effort and use
strategies to help you get there faster
but it has to start by doing things that
are energizing to you you're going to
spend so much time working guys you're
going to spend so much time working as
an entrepreneur
why not do stuff that makes you come
alive why not do stuff that gives you
energy
and so i want you to get out of your
head i want you to stop making decisions
first from your head i want you to stop
making decisions only because it's going
to help you get some goal
a short-term thinking and you're never
going to win doing it
big decisions with the heart big
decisions that give you energy look at
your calendar are you energized about
the week that's coming up
look at your account go load your
calendar right now load it on your
computer load it on your phone what
however you're loading your cat look at
it look at your calendar look at the
week ahead are you excited
are you excited about what you're about
to do
if not you're doing the wrong stuff
if you're only excited about 10 of your
calendar
you're only pouring your genius your
michael jordan level talent into 10 of
your time you're not going to get to
where you want to go you need to flip it
even if it doesn't make practical sense
at the beginning
because all great things are made
from the heart
all great things every great business
every great song every great creation
started from here from a place of
passion from place of purpose from place
of energy
and i want to put some pressure on you
guys to go off and chase it down because
so many entrepreneurs fail
and they lose a lot of money
it's not
an easy game but one of the biggest
reasons if not the number one reason is
because people pick an industry people
pick a business idea
solely because they're chasing an
opportunity down and they didn't love
doing the work there's a reason why in
my videos i say you have michael jordan
level talent i believe it it's true you
you
have michael jordan level talent at
something you are the best the
absolute best at something in the world
most people either one don't believe it
they don't believe that they're world
class at something or two they found the
thing that they could be world class at
but they don't have enough guts to chase
it down they don't believe in themselves
enough to chase them down here's the
thing
you need to first explore you need to
explore you got to search you got to say
yes you got to try things you don't know
that that tim hortons is your favorite
coffee cup
until you've tried it right you don't
know that sushi is your favorite food
until you've tried it sushi doesn't make
sense
right this is how we think our logical
brain starts to analyze things and
because it doesn't make sense we don't
try it sushi doesn't make sense you're
gonna take raw fish
mix it with rice put seaweed around it
and then eat it that sounds nasty right
if you've never tried it before it
sounds nasty but it's the best
a lot of the things that you might be
great at you are a judge and you're
dismissing because it doesn't make
logical sense you don't need to wrap
your head around it you need to wrap
your heart around it you have to feel it
you have to say yes and be willing to
try at least once if you don't know what
you're great at you have to say yes and
try things and you pay attention to the
feeling the most important thing is you
pay attention to the feeling how does it
make you feel you might not be great at
it
i expect not to get results at the
beginning of anything especially if it's
a new skill you're learning right expect
to suck at the beginning you're gonna
suck it's okay it's normal
but how does it make you feel does it
energize you do you want to come back
and do it again what would the boldest
version of you do think about your
mission think about your goals think
about what you are trying to accomplish
you've got what you're doing now but
think about what the boldest version of
you if you summoned the boldest version
of you into existence right now what
would he or she tell you to do so when i
did my tour earlier this year it was 90
days 23 cities and at first i want to do
it for free i love doing free coffee
shop meetups every time i travel to a
new city and i told my agent steve in
new york
hey man this is my idea he said you need
to charge for the event you got to play
bigger you got it you gotta do a bolder
version of you and it's it's freaked me
out it scared me because i don't want to
disappoint people and the idea of
charging for something and then me
disappointing people and then hitting
that fear every four days
because i got up in a new city every
three to four days for 90 days was me
being able to conquer my fears and so
steve pushed me and i have steve's voice
in my head it's like you need to play
bigger you got to do something bolder
what's the next step and so i'm looking
at my next tour coming up in 2020 around
my book built the serve and i'm trying
to think how do i make it even bigger
how do i make it even bolder because
what i've done has been great and it's
not trying to take away from what i've
done it's amazing i'm proud of myself
i'm grateful awesome and i know i'm
capable of more and i know i need to do
something at the next level because if i
want to go off and accomplish my mission
i need to because at the rate i'm going
right now i'm not going to hit a billion
people i'm not going to solve the
world's biggest problem
i'm not going to have the impact and
reach that i know i can have
unless i demand more boldness bigger
scale from myself on a daily basis and
so for me having steve's voice in my
head having elon musk's voice in my head
having steve jobs and nathan giannini
and my parents and kanye west and howard
schultz constantly in my head the
content that i make is for myself
it's selfish for myself and then i share
it with you guys and thankfully you like
it so i could build a business around it
and hire your team and and keep creating
more
what makes you bold what makes you come
alive and how do you summon that
creature on a daily basis
when you
if you wake up and you daily every day
consistently are bringing the boldest
version of you even for one year if you
woke up every day for one year and
someone the boldest version of you
your life is gonna look dramatically
different one year from today stop
thinking that you should be fearless if
you go through life fearless that means
you are playing small and not doing
anything that is worth doing you should
be dreaming big you should be pushing
boundaries and in that push comes fear
instead of trying to be fearless adopt a
mindset that you want to feel the fear
and do it anyway otherwise you will
never take on big projects and you'll
never accomplish your mission and you'll
always live below the potential that you
know you're capable of not asking for
help is selfish you might think that
trying to do everything yourself is
selfless that it's wrong to ask for help
and noble to do everything yourself but
you love helping people you love helping
others remember that joy you feel when
you help somebody and brought a smile to
their face knowing you made their week
by you not asking for help you're
cheating people of that opportunity to
bring a smile to their face stop being
selfish and start asking for help i came
up with this idea when i was at a video
game cafe so here's what happened i was
i was on a call with one of my big
customers at the time and i was in los
angeles and we're doing a google live
streaming to my youtube channel lots of
people watching
youtube live i'm interviewing him and
then the internet goes down like what
happened the power went out across all
of los angeles the power goes out and it
and it's down i got nothing the stream
is still live but i'm not there anymore
i left my client live on the stream and
he's he's not sure what happens he just
sees my camera goes down and then he
keeps going by himself for another 15-20
minutes waiting for me to come back and
he's he's embarrassed and it's awkward
and he doesn't know what he's doing
because the host
who has the audience there is now gone
and then eventually he just leaves
because well i don't know where evan is
but
thank you guys for watching
and it put him in a really difficult
situation i felt terrible i went back to
watching the livestream after like oh my
god i can't let that happen now it's out
of my control i you know
the internet goes down in los angeles
what am i supposed to do there's no
power anywhere so as soon as the power
gets back up i message my my client and
say hey man
i'm really sorry about that let's
reschedule it let's do it again when i'm
back home in toronto where i know i have
stable internet and and i want to do it
again for free no extra cost uh even
though we had almost finished the live
stream together
we're gonna do a whole other one for
free just because i want you to i want
to make this right for you great so we
come back to toronto it's like a week or
two later and my internet is pretty rock
solid in my home office i've never had
an internet issue really happen while i
was doing a live stream but i wanted to
make extra sure extra sure that this
time nothing happened because if
something happened the second time
just it would not be a good thing
so i asked my friend jay rise and i said
j rise i need i need a place that has
rock solid internet that i'm going to do
this live stream and nothing can go
wrong
and he said i got a place there's an
internet cafe that i go to
i'll introduce you to the owner i know
him and and you can do it there like
thank you so much so we go there i'm
there an hour early i'm setting up i'm
talking the owner i'm testing the gear
my microphone the headset all of it the
camera testing all of it just to make
sure that everything is working smoothly
i'm nervous because the last time it
failed on us
my client comes on we go live for half
an hour an hour i don't remember and and
it was smooth perfect no issues crisp
amazing internet blazing fast speeds
great time with the audience and we
delivered an awesome product
sigh of relief right i'm so pumped i go
talk to the owner say dude thank you man
it was perfect no complaints no problems
thank you so much how much do i owe you
and he said well
you were on the computer for about an
hour and a half and j raj is on the
computer for about an hour and a half
but i'll just bundle it together so
i think what he told me was like five
bucks or seven bucks or ten bucks or
something like are you kidding me i
would have paid a thousand dollars i
would have paid a lot of money just to
make sure that this went smoothly
because it's the it's the relationship
with my client at the time right
i said okay well let me great here's
here's the seven dollars that you wanted
awesome let me buy let me buy some some
stuff from behind the counter let me buy
some snacks from my friend j rice jaros
was hungry he needed to eat so like here
here's 20 bucks 25 bucks let me just buy
out a whole bunch of your snacks and
give it to him he's like no no you have
to do that man don't worry about it like
no i want to do it let me buy the snack
no no don't worry about it
the owner thought that he was doing a
good thing the owner thought
that he was being selfless said hey
don't worry but you don't have to do it
that just just paying for the internet
was enough for him but he was actually
being selfish
in that moment he was being selfish
because he cheated me
of the opportunity of one saying thank
you i wanted to pay more
i want to pay more
you're cheating me of the opportunity to
do it and you're cheating me of the
opportunity to help my friend jay rise
and give him some food
because he was hungry so we had to go
somewhere else you need to be willing
to bring other people in you need to be
willing to ask for help
yes you don't want to waste your time
yes you want to be respectful yes but
people love helping others we are built
to serve you want to help other people
that joy that you feel when you help
somebody out
allow it to come into other people's
hearts too if you quit on something too
soon that you still love you will regret
it for the rest of your life if you
don't love it anymore quit
move on you will never win doing work
that you hate but if you love it you
love it and you move on to something
else you will look back on this day and
regret it for the rest of your life that
you did not see it through most people
spend their entire life living with
regrets don't let that be you the
hardest decision i ever had to make in
my life was being an entrepreneur i
struggled a lot with the decision do i
want to be an entrepreneur and had this
opportunity to make 300 a month and earn
30 of a company versus going to work at
a job that i thought i wanted a job that
i've been preparing myself for that this
is what i wanted to do was in my high
school yearbook of this is where i was
going to be and here it was earning six
figures traveling around the world doing
the investment banking that i thought i
wanted to do
versus making 300 a month and only only
and owning 30 of a company and the thing
that allowed me to push through and be
an entrepreneur was me saying i don't
want to live with regret
that i would rather no one fail than not
know
and i gave myself a year i said i'm
going to give myself a year to do this
i could always go back and get another
job it may not be the same job probably
wouldn't be the same job may not be as
much pay may not be traveling as much as
this job was off for me to travel
but this entrepreneurial thing this
opportunity that i had i never knew if
it would come back again i thought maybe
this will never happen to me again and
so i decided to go for it and we
struggled and it was hard but i never
ended up having to go back and get
another job
and so if you're at an inflection point
if you're thinking about which path
should i take a or b
[Music]
lean in with your heart stop using your
head your head only understands the
world that currently exists lean in with
your heart
and ask yourself which decision will i
regret more if i don't do and then go
take that action
i became an entrepreneur because i
didn't want to regret not having at
least tried
and a great moment in my life came a
number of years later or one of the
people i went to university with came
back and said evan
i went down that path i became the
investment banker
and i hate my life
how do i become an entrepreneur
and i looked in his eyes and i saw the
desperation and the sadness
and
helped him but also was so grateful that
that wasn't me
because it could have been the fastest
way to learn anything is to model
someone who has done it before you you
don't need to have all the answers
yourself you don't need to have decades
of experience to win if you want to
shortcut your path and stop wasting time
you need to learn to model success so i
recently came back from speaking in
phoenix i was at an event with brendan
burchard andy graziosi and eric thomas
and a bunch of amazing speakers and i
have a lot of experience in speaking
i've been listed by forbes and inc
magazine as one of the greatest speakers
in the world super humbling
award but i still want to get better i
still want to learn i still want to
improve and so before getting on stage i
was talking to brendan burchard
backstage and he said hey i'm going to
watch your speech i'm going to finish my
interview here and i want to make sure
that i watch your speech and so i get on
stage and it's tons of fun i come back
out and brendan is running down the
aisle and he's got his hands up and he's
super excited and he said that was
amazing and he's telling me about how
great the the speech was and how much i
helped his audience and thanking me i
said amazing thank you so much
appreciate you let me ask you how do i
make it better you've done a lot of
these you've done more than i have
you're filling out you know huge rooms
full of people how can i get better i
want to model success i want to learn
from somebody who's done more than me
and chances are something great's going
to come back right like tell me i suck
brandon tell me i suck how do i improve
and he gave me a bunch of great feedback
he said one i need to use the stage more
so i was walking
kind of like this i was walking around
like this and at a slow pace because i
think as i'm going but he said no you
need to you need to walk faster you need
to walk faster like this and always
facing the audience and there's this
giant stage that i'm speaking at and he
said you got to make sure you hit both
sides of the stage at least four times
if you're speaking for an hour you gotta
hit
both sides of the stage at least four
times because evan what you did really
well was you you kept the people's focus
who are really in front of you in this
circle but the people who are out there
they didn't connect with you as much
great awesome feedback i got to take
that
got to take that home and improve he
also said to to be bigger and more
animated and this also makes sense for
my salsa background when you're doing
performance on stage you need to make
everything big because the people who
are up front can see you but the people
who are at the back they can't see the
expressions they can't see the movement
so it's got to be bigger than you would
normally do it and so even though i knew
that lesson from a different set of
experiences and salsa dancing
i hadn't applied it yet to my speaking
and so it was great it was great
learning experience and if i didn't ask
brendan hey what can you teach me what
how can i do better the worst case
scenario is he says there's nothing it
was perfect great i want to know how it
can improve though right he gave me two
pieces of advice that now i could take
into my next speaking gig to make it
even better right that's the idea of
model and success you find people who've
done it before who are better than you
at least one certain thing and ask them
how did they do it and ask them to
critique you and break you down because
through that you will shortcut your path
to get in there faster you will never
accomplish your business goals without a
team you have big goals big dreams big
ambitions it will never happen as a solo
entrepreneur you need to get out of the
mindset that you can do everything
yourself you can't you can go fast you
can stay small be nimble and being a
solo person and you still may always be
the most powerful and and important
individual in your company but you need
to build a team you need to scale up and
you need to get over your fears and hire
properly so i think a big reason why
most entrepreneurs don't end up building
successful teams because they get burned
because you don't know how to hire
properly because you hire somebody you
think this is great this person is going
to take over all of these things that i
don't want to do they're going to solve
my problems and then you can go on to
build bigger things for your business
the problem is that person that first
person rarely works out the first person
that you hire very rarely works out in
the business very rarely look at
companies and look at their success and
look at who employee number one two
three eight ten was and see are they
still around in the company very rarely
does it work out most of the time is
because you don't know what you're doing
because you don't know how to hire and
so you hire the wrong person i'm gonna
give you a process that i go through
that i think will really help you you
can learn from my success you have 24
people on my team and i want to shortcut
the path for you because i think the
hiring process is broken what do most
people do when they hire most people
they do some kind of job ad they post it
then you do this long interview process
right you're reading through resumes and
cover letters you bring them in for an
interview and then you get down to the
one person you end up hiring them and
what ends up happening a lot of times
that person doesn't work out or they're
just okay but you don't want to
fire them because you don't want to go
through that entire painful process
again to find somebody new it's too
painful it sucks you don't want to do it
again
here's how you flip the script one when
you're doing a job posting you you make
it one big ugly paragraph this is what i
do a job posting is one big ugly nasty
paragraph why because i want people to
be detail-oriented i want people to read
the whole thing i don't want to make it
easy
because a lot of times the job's not
going to be easy right so one big ugly
paragraph
in the middle of that big ugly paragraph
will be some skill testing question
it'll be something like tell me how many
subscribers i have on my youtube channel
tell me how many followers i have on
twitter and put it in the first line of
your application
eighty percent of people won't do it
eighty percent of people who apply to a
job will not answer the skill testing
question
why because they didn't even read the
application
they didn't read it they just saw the
title i'm looking for a video editor i'm
looking for an online marketer i'm
looking for xyz and they hit submit and
they send it to you now you're gonna
spend time reading their cover letter
reading their resume
going through their work history but
they spent five seconds on you you're
gonna spend five minutes ten minutes on
each of them and they spent five seconds
on you times up by 100 applicants that's
a lot of wasted hours no wonder why you
don't want to go on through that process
again it sucks eighty percent of people
will not read the job description you
need to filter them out
five percent of people then say great
tell me what your twitter account is and
i'll tell you how many followers you
have go to twitter type in evan
carmichael you can find me right you
need to have a little bit of
resourcefulness if you want to work for
an entrepreneur so already 85 of the
people are eliminated
they're gone now i only have to read
through 15 of the applications that come
through this is a lot better right these
are the people who put in the time who
read the application and they want to
work with you right let's talk about
that job posting what's in that big ugly
paragraph so you want to leave with the
values what are you staying for what are
you all about evening in the job title
right away i'm looking for
a video marketer that believes in
entrepreneurs
and then talk about what my company is
all about what my mission is what i'm
trying to accomplish right before
getting to
the the job description and the roles
and responsibilities
i want to leave with the mission because
somebody's going to look at that and say
this is the stupidest thing i've ever
seen amazing don't apply or they'll say
i love this finally
i want to work extra hard to apply for
that company right the people who are
good fits for you from a values and
culture point of view they will
self-select in that's what you want so
don't just tell me in your job at what
the roles and responsibilities are
lead with the mission so lead with the
mission leave with the values tell me
what what your company is trying to do
then you have your skill testing
question and then you tell me what the
job description is all about like what
am i going to be doing on a day-to-day
basis what's my role what do you want me
to do every day for you
right and then i'll at the end put some
kind of qualitative question in as well
so the skill testing question is how
many followers do i have the qualitative
one would be tell me about
uh who your favorite entrepreneur is and
why i don't really care what their
answer is some people say richard
branson or elon musk or some big name
some people will say my dad because he
started his own little grocery store
great i don't really care what the
answer is i just want to see if they
actually care because if you're working
for me
i want you to actually care about
entrepreneurs that's the mission that
we're on right
great after that you still get a whole
bunch of people who will apply
next what most people do is go to a job
interview i think a job interview is a
giant waste of time i think most people
hire from a job interview and it doesn't
actually test for the skills that you're
trying to hire right so if i'm looking
for a video editor as an example right
i'm looking for a new video edited for
my channel
how well they do in a job interview
doesn't translate doesn't map to their
success as a video editor
right maybe they're super nervous when
they're talking to people
maybe they're really shy maybe they
can't articulate themselves via voice
very well right and so if i'm judging
their abilities based off of how they
communicate face to face that's not what
i'm trying to hire for now if i'm hiring
a sales person that's a different story
right they can sell me on on themselves
they need to be good face-to-face but
for video editor
it's the wrong skill set and so i think
people
hire off of a job interview which tests
the wrong skills so the best thing you
can do is go on a trial so anybody who
answers my job at and will give me the
skill testing question and then tell me
who their favorite entrepreneur is and
why i'll then hire them on a trial
i'll give them five paid hours
no job interview five paid hours for a
job that i think will take them two
now why do i do this
i'm not a micromanager i don't want to
micromanage people it drives me nuts i
don't want to be on your shoulder and
say hey did you get this done did you
get that done it's not my style so i
need people who will self-manage and
people who won't milk me
so i'll pay you for up to five hours for
a job that i think should take you to
and here's what i'm looking for one if
you took the full five hours either one
you're milking me
right you should have done it a lot
faster but you know you can get five
hours so you're gonna say it took you
five hours amazing that's a cheap way to
test if somebody's a good fit for you or
not or two they're just really slow and
incompetent either way you don't want to
have that person on your team so i want
the person who's gonna come in at five
so i want the person who's going to say
hey i know i can have five hours but
it's only actually gonna take me two so
let me do it in two that's the person i
want on my team
from there what i'm looking for is
somebody who goes above and beyond the
call of duty so somebody who doesn't
just do the thing that i ask for but
injects their own style tries to find a
way to make it better so video editor is
a great example when i went through my
video editing hiring process
i hired maybe 20 people on a trial 15 20
people on a trial something like that
paid trial up to five hours christina
who's been my editor for the past
i don't know six years she came in and
said hey evan here's what you asked for
i had a very clear
requirements here's what i want you to
do here's what you asked for
but what you did kind of sucks and
here's how i would do it
and she made something that was better
right so she gave me what i asked for
and then went above and beyond to give
me something better
that's the person i want to hire right
and that's the person i want to keep on
my team and that's why she's been with
me for
six
or so years
right so that process is how you find
great people and in that process of
actually working with them on a project
if you are working for me to be a video
editor i want to see how well you edit a
video not how well you respond to an
interview question not how well you can
write a cover letter or a resume it's
testing for the wrong skills
and so that's the process and that saves
time and it brings the right people in
and then it allows you to scale and
leverage your business so that you are
not doing everything yourself because
you have an important mission
you're trying to help people but you
can't do everything yourself
you need to get out of that mindset you
need to stop doing everything yourself
you need to start by bringing on people
even part-time the first person to hire
us for one hour a day
that's it bring people on part-time to
free up your time get people who are
better than you at that thing free up
your time to focus on the things that
you have michael jordan level talent at
and that's how you start to scale
it may not work out the first time it
may not work out the second time don't
quit on building a team because
everybody who's done the thing that you
want to do all your heroes all of your
mentors everybody you look up to they
built a team and you need to too
[Music]
if you want to watch another top 10
rules of evan carmichael check out the
video next to me continue to believe i
will see you there you get motivated you
get inspired you get pumped up something
happens in your life that then makes you
want to go and drive further harder
faster let's go
and then you fall off the track